hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast training competency
assessment and best practice in aseptic
technique I'm Brenda Kelly Kim of lab
roots and i'll be your monitor moderator
for today's event we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button in the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your question through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Angela
curtain Angela curtain is head of
veterinary services and CBS training
unit at the Imperial College of London
she currently leads a team of Veterinary
Surgeons to share best practice and
particularly the promotion of the 3 R's
that's head of training she was
responsible for monitoring and
developing training programs at Imperial
College I will now turn it over to
Angela curtain for her presentation hi
my name is Angelica and thanks to Brenda
for her very kind introduction today
I'll be talking you through training
competency assessment and best practice
in aseptic technique here's a brief
overview of my presentation the first
section is the lecture is going to focus
on how people learn looking at different
learning styles because these may
influence your choice and type of
training program
the next session we'll look at types of
training programs available split into
various sections including books
lectures course notes video tutorials or
some examples of those practical
hands-on stuff that you can do to make
training fun this will be further split
down into alternatives to animals the
use of cadavers dedicated hands-on
training programs that are available and
working under supervision I'll then be
able to say what we've done here within
our own academic establishment some
feedback from the users here and how
we're going to promote this with our
ongoing communication program the final
bit of my talk will focus on different
types of assessment and assessment
criteria but i will pay particular
attention to one particular area of work
based assessment called direct
observation of procedural skills
abbreviated to dupes finally I'll wrap
up with some additional considerations
and then provide some ideas about plans
for ongoing training programs here in
the UK I'm hoping by the end of this
presentation we will have achieved the
fern a following learning outcomes
you'll have an awareness of the types of
aseptic surgical training programs
available you'll be able to listen
consume but also should be available
within aseptic procedure rooms have an
idea how to create your own posters
which act as an aide memoire for
researchers to assist with the
maintenance of a sexist and then because
I've shown you some examples of this
direct observation of procedural skills
assessment you'll be able to set up your
own forum for assessing competency in
aseptic surgery so the first part of my
lecture really goes back to teaching and
looking at how people learn
information enters our brain in various
ways the three main ways are by sight
hearing and touch which one you learn
you use the most is called your learning
style visual learners will learn by
sight auditory learners will learn by
hearing and tactile learners will learn
by touch visual learners prefer to see
information such as pictures diagrams
cartoons or demonstrations as they hear
or absorb things they actually visualize
these things in their head and this
helps them remember this can mean they
can be easily distracted in lectures
where there's no visual impact when
they're working with course notes they'd
like to either doodle in them or use
colorful colorful highlighters to mark
the text they therefore benefit from
using teaching age such as charts photos
videos and illustrated notes when
studying auditory learners prefer to
hear information in the spoken word this
can mean that they can absorb a lecture
with little effort they may not
necessarily need careful low notes to
learn and because they're concentrating
on their hearing ability they may avoid
eye contact in order to concentrate
better by reading out aloud this helps
them absorb information and they may or
may not prefer background music when
they study because of this the traits
they'll show will then prefer to talk
through a problem orally rather than
have to read complex written notes
finally the tactile or kinesthetic
learners learn things from moving doing
and touching by being hands-on as I just
said they then the touch is really
important to them so because of this in
a traditional lecture setup they might
find it difficult to concentrate so they
should be given something to do and so
sometimes they entertain
themselves by writing out in four
important facts so he actually absorbs
information in their brain as part of
the learning process they definitely
prefer hands-on activities and may find
it more beneficial to study in short
blocks role-playing can help them learn
and remember important ideas so because
we've got all those different facilities
that visually auditory and the tactile
ways of learning this may influence your
type a training program obviously some
of these training programs you may
already have set up in your
establishments and so this is just
providing you some additional
information the most traditional method
is by learning by books and papers there
are loads of laboratory animal science
surgery reference books out there
veterinary wrongs and medical ones as
well you may have your own presentation
set up in house with detailed course
notes and there's a variety of online
reference material available some of it
very good and also we should remember
that scientists like reading about
different methodologies and the papers
that they publish one thing I did want
to share with you which some of you may
not be aware of is the lights as guiding
principles for repairing for and
undertaking aseptic surgery this is
prepared by the laboratory animal
science association section called
education training and ethics of which
I'm a member the contents of the
document is split up into the area
sections this includes preparation prior
to surgery then preparing the animal in
the surgery and the surgeon itself what
to do to maintain an aseptic field and
then some details about recovery and
post-operative care and the ongoing
monitoring of the outcomes of surgery
the way and the style that this
particular guiding principles is drafted
is aimed at both new and experienced
researcher
the outlines of which can be used to
develop your own standard operating
procedures which is abbreviated to SOPs
which are appropriate to the species
that you'll work with your staff and to
your facility and can be used to improve
the standards currently used for surgery
within your own working environment the
link for this will pop up in your screen
now there is a variety of members of the
laser etes group or from a variety of
backgrounds and when we got together to
draft the principles we deliberately set
these standards high and sometimes
quoted as being aspirational so when
using this particular document take
what's appropriate for you and the type
of work that you're undergoing within
your research environment use it as a
way of assisting improving your
standards for recovery surgery and
hopefully it will have some fresh ideas
as I said I think there's something in
this particular document for both new
and experienced researchers and it's
widely used here within the UK as a
training reference guide I'm now going
on to look at what is there visually
which again can benefit some of the
learners that like using your visual
input there's a very good website which
is developed by the newcastle university
and the NC three r's centre and that
stands for the national center of the
three RS which is here in the UK is
hosted on the institute of animal
technology website called the procedures
with care it really is an excellent
tutorial it's developed to help research
workers apply best practice in aseptic
surgical technique it's broken down its
various modules so it's very easy to
study and come back to and it's very
interactive as well we use it a lot as
part of our
in-house training program and feedback
from those participants has been very
positive the next video area I'd like to
highlight to you which I'm sure many of
you will have been aware of is called
Jove Joe stands for the journal of
visualized experiments and this was the
world's first peer reviewed scientific
video Journal it really is a great
journal and the way that it's really had
his biggest impact is by providing all
this information in a different format
that's easy available to researchers for
developing their techniques now
establishments do have to pay to
subscribe to Joe but the particular web
link there is actually open access so is
available to all I haven't actually
asked the congress organizers to put
this website live as a box on your
tutorial today because it actually has
an auditory sound that would interfere
with me speaking at the moment and
obviously I want you to listen to me but
really do go back and look at this
because it really is an excellent
tutorial guide also if you have a look
at the other types of techniques and
information available it could be
something that you approach your
establishment of your librarian and
actually then start subscribing to so
you can get the full range of learning
materials that's available finally and a
wrap up of the other types of videos
that are around a variety of
manufacturers have actually got very
good detailed training programs on areas
such as telemetry implantation or mini
pumps sometimes these are provided on
their websites or buy a CD or DVD which
will send to you you will find a variety
of surgical and aseptic technique videos
available on
to a word of warning when using YouTube
although I do use it very frequently
myself is to actually check the quality
and the content of these videos before
you use them as your routine and
training aids some of them are very good
but do be just wary of that and finally
I think because all moving forward into
this technology and there's nothing to
stop establishments in yourself
developing your own and there's some
very good and software available to help
you do that moving away from videos onto
sort of practical hands-on stuff which i
think is what everybody enjoys the most
looking at some non-animal alternatives
we've got some pictures up here of some
alternatives such as artificial skin or
suture blocks but instead or as well as
those you could use other inanimate
objects such as oranges or bananas or
whatever you fancy really there are some
veterinary suppliers and I'm sure some
medical suppliers but coming from my
veterinary background are more aware of
the veterinary suppliers that actually
have their own specialized synthetic
surgical models available for purchase
and we've got a couple of examples
they're being shown one idea that you
may wish to develop yourself is if
you're from an academic Institute or an
industry that has its own bio
engineering department and is very good
at creating things in plastics it could
be that you approach them with some
ideas which would support the three
hours in developing some surgical
synthetic models which are more relevant
too nice and too laboratory rats the use
of cadavers is widely used within our
establishment as part of our monthly
practical home office modular training
courses and we set up surgical tables
with full sets of instruments and have
the candidates drape the animals they
don't actually
grab for surgery I will say but they try
to maintain a septic field and the
particular example that we use that
seems to get good feedback is a spin and
ectomy in a rat we choose this
particular technique because it involves
a lot of the basic surgical procedures
such as making the first incision some
blunt dissection opening up the body
cavity identifying the appropriate organ
ligating blood vessels and then we
enclosure what we've got another picture
of there is something I got off the
internet which is I have heard that some
suppliers would go to the butchers or
abattoirs and get things like pig
trotters to simulate suturing the skin
so again there is a range of material
available depending on what country
you're based in and the national
legislation there may be the
availability to actually attend
dedicated hands-on surgical training
courses for variety of techniques
examples that I've got included there
include microsurgery reproductives
courses and telemetry also I wanted to
alert you to another set of guidelines
which the laboratory animal science
association have put together which may
be of interest to you is called the
guiding principles for the supervision
and assessment of competence as required
under EU and UK legislation it split up
into various sections including your
legal responsibilities here within the
UK and EU there's a section on
supervision how to choose your best
supervisor looking at competence
defining competence and then what I
can't cover here in the lecture today
and it's as a couple of additional
examples for companies competency
assessment using those a binary and a
school system
for some basic surgical techniques so it
may give you some further examples of
how you want to develop things yourself
within the workplace that you're based
at so what worked well here well what
we're finding gets the most positive
feedback is the hands on staff and we've
also find what's works well is actually
making teaching involving small groups
with some peers so actually researchers
can pass on recommendations between
themselves you can identify people that
are going to become good Assessors good
trainers themselves get into an informal
discussion and as well as promoting best
practice at the same time the challenges
that we faced is that we have a very
large academic community here within
Imperial College there's over a hundred
over 800 personal licensees those are
researchers who can perform hands-on
procedures under the animal scientific
procedures act because of trying to
reach that wide base communication has
been absolutely vital and I've got a
couple of examples and coming up at how
we started to advertise the support and
training that we've got in place here so
one thing that we do is we've made it
very obvious that the vets and other
people are available to actually put
together refresher training practicals
in areas such as aseptic technique but
also we offer them in areas such as
post-operative care and recovery
anesthesia and pain relief again it's
very good to have people approach you as
well as putting out regular dates
yourselves where these refreshes are
available
also what we've tried to do is create a
poster with minimum standards for
aseptic surgery in rodents and this was
one of the learning outcomes that I hope
to share with you and help develop
following the end of this lecture so we
split it up into various sections and
we've printed these and we've displayed
them in prominent positions in any of
the procedure rooms where aseptic
surgery may be performed throughout our
facilities so the first section focuses
on instruments it reminds the
researchers the instruments should be
autoclaved and then talks about the
practicalities of batch operations also
reminds them that all consumables should
be sterile so this includes your gloves
your drapes and suture materials the
middle section is split up into animal
preparation some basic guidelines about
prepping the animal for surgery we
recommend here at Imperial that the hair
is clipped and aseptic Lee prepared
using either a poverty in iodine based
solution or chlorhexidine from our
establishment base and from working with
our vet team here at the moment we're
trying to prevent animals being
over-prepared with alcohol because we
mainly work with mice and rats as the
alcohol evaporates it has a chilling
effect so could actually be detrimental
and increasing the chance of hypothermia
so I agree it does have its place and
that we are promoting the others over
the excessive use of alcohol and then
finally there's a section for the
surgeon there just reminding them how to
maintain a sepsis and if they do break a
sepsis at any point and they should
either change their gloves or and try to
have sterile swabs available to maneuver
any equipment and that they may need to
touch during the operation
the second half of my presentation is
going to look at assessment systems
finally moving on to the direct
observational procedural skills the
so-called oops form that were currently
in the process of rolling out here so
what is an assessment well one
definition of assessment is assisted
systematic procedure for measuring a
trainees progress or level of
achievement against a defined criteria
to make a judgment about the training
the purpose of the assessment system is
to determine where the trainees are
meeting the standards of competence and
performance specified for aseptic
techniques or surgical procedures I
think what's great is they can be used
to provide a systematic and
comprehensive feedback as part of the
ongoing learning cycle they determine
whether a trainees have acquired the
common and speciality based knowledge
sound judgment operative technical
skills and generic professional behavior
requires practice at the level of the
local establishment or facility in the
designated surgical procedure an ideally
the assessment system should address all
the domains of best practice and conform
to the principles laid down by the
national authorities so in looking
assessments there are various criteria
which they should ideally matched just
going to run through these now in the
next couple of slides they should be
valid to ensure that there are valid
we're using a method of work based
assessments that are you know actually
going to take place in real life within
the workplace they're reliable in order
to increase reliability there's multiple
measures and outcomes the so-called
DEP's assessment makes use of several of
dirt observers judgments can utilize a
multiple of assessment methods and
should take place ideally at frequent
intervals so-called refresher
assessment of competency feasibility
when putting together an assessment of
competency training program you could
have gold plated ideas loads and loads
of paperwork but you've got to make
something that's feasible the
practicalities of new assessments should
be taken into account it shouldn't add a
significant amount of time to the
workplace to ask being assessed and the
Assessor should be able to complete the
scoring of feedback part of the
assessment within five to ten minutes
cost-effectiveness we all have to work
within budgets so once staff had been
trained in the assessment process the
only additional cost should be the extra
time taken for assessments and feedback
and the induction of new designated
trainers and Assessors the most
substantial extra time investment will
be in the regular appraisal process for
units that did not previously have such
a system so there might be a lot of time
put into developing their systems but
once they're in place you know they are
going to be worthwhile and cost
effective if you're going to assess
you've got to have the opportunity for
feedback there's an actual typo in the
first sentence there so I apologize for
that so they should actually be
structured about not just learning but
also the teaching and the assessment
quality structured feedback is a
fundamental component of high quality
assessments and should be incorporated
throughout these there should be
hopefully a positive impact on learning
so again by giving that immediate
feedback you're able to facilitate that
process so it's part of a continual
learning process and also allow time for
self-reflection that self reflection on
what went well what didn't go well
during a competency assessment can
actually help develop a person's
training and help them and progress
further throughout their career
so no the view of work based assessments
they're there to provide feedback to
trainers but also the training is as
part of the learning cycle the picture
there is called Miller's triangle which
shows the development of all not just
what you know but what you're able to do
practically as you get more confident
and competent in doing a certain task
ideally the outcome from all of these
work based assessments is that they
should be viewed as part of the process
and throughout the training of an
individual person to enable the trainee
to build on their feedback and chart
their own progress so on to what we're
using here and developing at Imperial
College and we actually got the idea
from what's currently being used in a
lot of medical scenarios within the UK
and I expect elsewhere it's called a
direct observation of procedural skills
and it's a work based assessment the
assessment involves an Assessor
observing the trainee performing a
practical procedure within the workplace
the assesses evaluation is recorded on a
structured form which is used by the
Assessor to provide the training with
structured feedback this flow chart here
summarizes real really the overall
process of undertaking the assessment
process so firstly there should be some
guidance notes not just for the Assessor
that for the trainee so everyone knows
what's expected from each party that's
involved in that process then obviously
the scheduling no timetable of when
these assessments are going to take
place which obviously can be organized
with direct discussion between the
assessor and the trainee coming to the
day itself the assessment process and
the Assessor needs to set in advance as
standards for assessment in the criteria
that they're going to be
looking at the student and evaluating
them against and these assessment form
should be provided in advance the person
that's being assessed so they can
actually be you and see what they're
going to be assessed against so you've
got the form itself forming an integral
part of this process and then what's a
form has been completed what is really
vitally important is feedback and again
making it a two-way process once this
feedback and guidance has been provided
and that particular form can actually be
given to the trainee as part of their
training portfolio and their ongoing
personal development and training within
the research field so that might all
sound scary it isn't all alien though
you're able to build this into an
existing structures you have people
doing tasks whether the animal husbandry
tasks surgical tasks procedural tasks
day in day out just building this
assessment to fit in with that the great
thing about it is it can involve a wide
range of star for different levels both
medical scientific and animal care staff
can all play their role see the formal
part of assessment and as an opportunity
to train not just assess and by using
this structured form which I'll come on
to now in more depth hopefully it's a
way of formalizing the existing
supervision process which is in place
and it helps improve feedback so what
I'm going to do now is run through a
direct observation of procedural skills
assessment but this isn't actually
directed for aseptic technique and I do
apologize for those of you that would
love one for aseptic technique but there
were so many procedures that I've found
in my own head that if I use something
that was very common such as an
intraperitoneal or IP injection and a
mouse you would then all be very very
familiar with this and then could see
how this could be
quite different scenarios so when you're
setting up a dupes assessment for any
task for whatever it is you need to
actually stand back and think what do I
want to assess how can I actually break
this down so when looking for this
particular example of an IP injection
and a mouse we broke it down into the
following assessment criteria all
components of the task firstly we wanted
the person to be able to check their
license Authority and their training
record then to actually have a criteria
to make sure they were wearing the
correct personal protective equipment or
PPE not just from an NAA or laboratory
animal allergens point of view but also
for helping minimizing infections spread
throughout the unit they would need to
be able to confirm the animals
identification and also the cage their
knowledge of how to choose the correct
needle and syringe and equipment and how
to handle these their dexterity going
onto the animal obviously that's a very
important factor being able to handle
the mouse correctly but also
sympathetically the procedure itself
knowledge of the correct site for this
injection and the volume and frequency
of injection then thinking of
record-keeping which is very important
from a quality assurance and compliance
point of view knowing where the
information needs to be recorded and
then what's great about a dupes
assessment is you can actually use a
certain criteria on it for assessing
professional attitude and interaction
within the workplace so again there are
things to set up but once you've got
them set up it does become very easy so
you have to think to yourself what would
be an immediate failure so we class this
as below expectations so if someone came
in to be assessed and they failed to
check the correct legal authorities and
the animal detail
they failed to choose the correct
personal protective equipment they have
poor animal handling with the risk of
injury or the animals showing signs of
distress and they then had an unsuitable
sight volume and preparation for dosing
one step up for that is the so called
borderline threshold category where they
were able to catch and restrain the
mouse but perhaps did this hesitantly to
begin with there was a poor choice of a
preparation or suitable equipment and
they needed more than one attempt to
perform the injection and what I will
say at this point is when you're
performing the assessments if at any
point the animals welfare is very
greatly adversely affected you would
step in as an assessor and stop them
performing that task so then for a
standard pass or so-called meets
expectations they've met the following
criteria they've checked the right
license authorities and the animals ID
they're able to remove the cap match
from the cage handle it empathetically
with the body supportive and again what
we've built into the criteria there is
we also want them to maintain both
breasts practice when they release the
animal back into the cage they're able
to give the injection at the first
attempt have the correct choice of
needle size and syringe the appropriate
volume and keep the records updated and
then you have one category on from that
I suppose you could call it the A+ or
gold star they exceed expectations so
they meet all the criteria above when in
addition to that they show some quiet
confidence and capability and empathetic
animal handling they're able to explain
their reasons for the choice of
equipment with respect to the three
hours they have excellent manual
handling dexterity with the dose
administration
and they can explain some knowledge of
any other particular criteria and
knowledge in managing serial injections
so all of that criteria is now
summarized on this particular form so
eventually this is how easy it would
look this is what the Assessor would
have in front of them and all of those
criteria and this form will have been
provided to the training in advance of
the assessments they know what's
accepted of them so we've got the
various categories down on the side
there so we've got two category on legal
kaliga land compliance issues animal
welfare procedural issues the
professionalism which I've said is so
vital to import important to assess as
well and a particular section they're
dedicated isn't three hours we then have
the tick boxes going across the top
where the candidate either exceeds
expectations meets expectations is
borderline or scores below expectations
so what happens for the actual scoring
so to be competent and I will flash back
to the previous slide in a minute just
to refresh everyone to be competent
you've got to score one borderline score
or better for all of those assessment
criteria if a candidate scores below
expectations at any point or two
borderline schools they recommended to
continue supervision so again this is
very important for all researchers who
may perhaps perceive as cess mminton
competency as a hindrance to their work
at no point are you saying that they
should stop their work completely but
more that they need further training and
continue under supervision so if I just
go back to the previous slide refresh
you and if at any one point they scored
below expectations that would be an
immediate flag to continue under
supervision and if they scored to
borderline again that would flag for
more supervision but if they meet
expectations exceed expectations or just
have one score in the borderline box
then you canna deem them an assessment
as competent for that particular
technique it's very important the
environment when you're conducting this
assessment everyone's got to be aware of
what standards you're trying to achieve
so make sure that both the Assessor in
the trainee have read and understood
their guide guidance if people are
working under a lot of pressure and
things are getting very stressful this
time constraints is that really the best
scenario and environment to assess their
competence on that particular day make
sure that there is enough time for the
assessment and for feedback and if you
do have to give negative feedback check
the appropriate place to give this
remember as an Assessor you need that
form documented you need it completed so
have it with you make notes and score as
the person is doing the procedure the
benefits of using the assessment form is
it give structure to the encounter it
encourages systematic approach if you do
develop some generic forms it could be
that some of the assessment criteria are
not applicable so you would just put you
know na for those it reduces bias and
it's very very helpful in providing
feedback it can help identify areas of
further development or training and it
can be a useful environment commentating
on professional behavior so again your
ability to feedback is very important
and integral to this part of the process
the feedback should be immediate however
and there are certain teaching methods
where you know feedback can be developed
and the way that you give
feedback is very important so you might
want to consider using what's known as a
modified Pendleton framework so to get
into a discussion starting off with what
the trainee felt felt went well what the
Assessor observed went well what the
trainee would do differently in the
future and then some developmental or
training suggestions from the Assessor
focus on what you saw and what was
observed that is the purpose for work
based assessments and I use the form you
know as part of the ongoing training
records for the person that you're
assessing so Cindy's and some domes do
you use the deep system to review your
current standards but think about what's
practical when you develop these dupes
forms you do have to try them out review
them and optimize them gather feedback
from all of your Assessors but also the
trainees you know it's a two-way process
encourage its use as a training document
and a new reference and use it as a base
for discussion and debate one idea that
we've had about ideas of trying them out
reviewing and optimizing is thinking
back to our video training reference
guides and what's available on YouTube
I'm not going to name any examples but
you could actually on YouTube go and
review some surgical techniques or any
type of techniques and try out your new
form and say well would I pass them as
competent or not and that can actually
then highlight areas of your assessment
criteria that you may need to factor
into a new form
I'm hoping that you don't ignore the
importance for assessment and competency
in the workplace or come away thinking
it isn't practical it might seem you
know a sort of like a pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow at the moment then
even the simplest things can be improved
start with small procedures and work up
to more bigger complex ones there is a
myth out there within the research world
that rodents are resistant to infection
because they don't necessarily show over
signs of infection and there is further
need for more data to be published on
subclinical infection and how this can
influence results but I've already had
feedback from many researchers here
within our facilities saying that since
they've improved their aseptic standards
their results have been more reliable
and more reproducible and their models
of disease are giving them better better
results it might seem scary but don't
bury your head in the sand our future
plans then I think it's very important
not just here within the UK but also
internationally to make more of sharing
our training resources whether these are
online or behind you know secure
websites one of the courses that I've
attended in the UK looking at the Duke
system and the intention of that is that
everyone who attends the course will
then develop their own dupes but
actually share these within the
community and I think that's going to be
very important for the transfer of
training records and skills I really
love not just the hands-on stuff but the
visual side of training and education so
I want to develop more in-house video
tutorials win the process of identifying
more dedicated trainers and Assessors
and we're developing the deeps system at
the moment
one thing I haven't been able to touch
on due to the time constraints of this
lecture is the importance of good
theater technicians these are vital for
research support I am hoping that we can
develop some introductory training
courses based around maintaining good a
sepsis and good facilities within our
theaters but all of this hinge is around
maintaining good communication and one
of the initiatives that we've had is a
monthly animal research newsletter which
is sent out to all of our users involved
with animal research which highlights
areas of best practice but also training
so to conclude I hope this lecture has
given you a better understanding of
assessment tools and processes seeing it
as a place to use your existing people
places and opportunities hopefully you
would have come away with some ideas of
how to train your trainers and Assessors
and trainees but on all kinds of new
processes and lay any anxieties see it
as an informative process and a way to
improve and develop your learning skills
I'd like to thank you for listening and
I will now pass you over to the
moderator Brenda Thank You Angela for
that informative presentation before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question on the poster
for minimum standards for surgery in
rodents your note on the bottom that all
consumables shown are available from CBS
do you charge for these
hello and we're actually building in
these charges into our theater charge
again it would depend on the size of
your facility whether this is feasible
or not and we used to have a process
where all of these would be have to be
purchased by individual research grants
however to promote best practice and
make this really available we reviewed
that situation and we feel that we're
able to actually incorporate this into
our theater charges makes our next
question we train for a use of
chlorhexidine scrub followed by seventy
percent ethanol rins with an emphasis on
not soaking not soaking the site with
evan off what other procedure of
products do you prefer to use hi yeah I
totally accept and don't you know forbid
that's not the word but you know I
realized there is a place for ethanol
products and alcohol products and but in
my past experience with inexperienced
researchers and there could be the
tendency to over soak and so the two
products that we recommend are either a
diluted iodine remedies solution or a
don't like diluting chlorhexidine
solution and we use these on the
animal's skin without the alcohol
afterwards and this is just really based
with our small rodent models are mice
and
rats for larger species I would probably
own for my own personal preference and
for working in that Andrey practice use
an ethanol scrub or wash over that but
just for the small rodents we have a
recommendation that we're not using the
ethanol and that's a Brenda our next
question do you have an SOP for every
training process or procedure or do you
have a list of active activities they
need to be confident in like blood
collection in a rodent high and at the
moment to be honest we don't have a full
list but that is actually our aim is to
have a full list of here is your blood
sampling here is your subcutaneous
injection here is your look and I think
here is how to implant a subcutaneous
mini pump how here is how to work a
gaseous anesthetic station here is how
to going on too much but yes our basic
thing is to make a full list and some of
these skills are transferable though so
once someone has been assessed in part
of a more complicated aseptic surgical
procedure things like an aesthetic
handling of animals knowledge of depth
of anaesthesia monitoring anesthesia can
actually have been reassessed within
other protocols as a whole I hope that
makes sense hand back
our next question what about frequency
of training frequency of training is
really dependent on how often the
procedures be informed and again it's
it's a ongoing process for us at the
moment and so if a person has had an
absence of work or hasn't done a
procedure for maybe six months to a year
we would ask for some reassessment of
competency at that point if they're
performing the same procedures day in
day out a regular frequency at the
moment our standards are set that we are
going to reassess people in techniques
every three years again this is
something that needs to be discussed the
practicalities of within your
establishment but again this would be
for somebody who really is doing it on a
routine basis they've been signed off as
competent they then continue to do it
there would be other systems in place to
flank concerns if there were any
concerns about training or supervision
and reassessment could take place at any
point and again should hopefully be seen
as a benefit of someone's ongoing
learning and training program okay great
our next question how do you deal with a
severe failure
and how we would deal with a severe
failure is we would stop work
immediately while some investigations
were taking place and part of those
investigations would look at compliance
issues as well as training issues animal
welfare issues and based on that there
is then guidelines within the UK and
then involve our Authority the Home
Office so we would have to involve the
Home Office if any of these guidelines
or values were breached we would then
have a training program set up with
what's known as our main training and
competency officer looking at the
supervision processes and sign off same
place within that particular group and
look on improving those as well and it
would only be once everything had been
reassessed better training in place
reassessment that that person would be
deemed competent to perform procedures
unsupervised again to Brenda our next
question I have a lot of trouble getting
the message across about the importance
of aseptic technique is there anything
in your training program that can be
added to make sure they use the SF
techniques taught and I've recently
found a very very good article looking
at the importance of a septics from a
medical human and perspective and the
national guidelines and it's dated 2011
which is it is fairly you know sort of
modern and relevant and and all of the
guidelines there clickable to humans
are again applicable to our animal
models and it really influences how you
know breaking a sepsis can alter normal
physiological values and so I think that
by providing scientific references that
are up to date getting into discussions
of researchers that can really encourage
their uptake of best practice and a
sepsis and so I can provide that
reference if you're able to leave your
email with some of the course organizers
our next question is there an expiration
to practical training given to a
researcher sorry could you repeat the
question Brenda I just didn't get the
first word no problem is there an
expiration to practical training given
to our researcher there isn't and you
know we don't say you you have to have
practical training we find that it's the
best method you know either using
alternatives or looking at the best use
of tissues and cadavers that are
available via other research groups so
it's not like you must have practical
training but personally I've just found
it it's the best learning method to be
able to demonstrate things to people to
talk through things practically it just
seems a very good learning method
compared to rich in reference material
our next question in your experience how
long does it take to train an undergrad
with no previous experience it's a bit
of an open question and it depends on
exactly what they're wanting to be
trained in for a minor procedure and by
minor procedure in a rodents I would
class this as something that isn't
opening up a body cavity that takes less
than maybe 10 or 15 minutes to perform
so an example would be the implantation
of a subcutaneous slow-release pellet
with a couple of skin sutures and the
entire training program would probably
take i would estimate probably three
months in total and again we haven't
really got defined time spans for each
person because it depends on their
practical abilities their dexterity you
know how often they're able to you know
work under supervision but it's not
something I agree that can be mastered
overnight you you are thinking of
several months and it could take a lot
longer depending on the individual game
for more complex techniques you know
could tape you know going off for a year
perhaps to Brenda
question do you charge for training
sessions we are currently struggling
with that right now as some of our
facilities do charge and others have not
we don't charge for our in-house
training we are privileged that we have
quite a large vet team here and also a
large team of animal care staff and
experience pills or researchers as we
call them who we work alongside so us
our ongoing training we don't charge for
and there is in the UK what's known as a
home office modular course which all
people within the UK before they granted
a personal license of the Home Office
have to sit and all the Home Office
course providers do make a charge for
this again it's just thinking high in
the sky of what is a reasonable charge
for you know dedicated courses we don't
have a dedicated to limit recall setup
but again if you if you were thinking of
it a dedicated course and then I think
it would be reasonable to charge for
that but again we're just very
privileged with the size of our facility
and the resources at the one-to-one
training and the small group training we
don't actually charge for back to Brenda
I hope back to Brendan sorry
unfortunately we are out of time I'd
like to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event and thank Angela as
well for her informative presentation
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 2015
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thank you goodbye